let's go next to dennis from newark
dennis so what is happening in beautiful
newark new jersey today
hi david can you hear me
yes i can
wonderful um you know things
uh in newark aren't too great okay
and um in new jersey in general uh
you know things could be better
but um i'm i'm having some
really deep concerns
about the state of
not necessarily the state of democracy
but just the state of politics
um
and that's
because there's an idea that i want to
propose to you
okay
it seems like
the the shift of the political spectrum
to the right
is
giving
the quote-unquote liberal media so say
msnbc
some voices
um
some republican or former republican
voices like tara set mayor sir michael
singleton who i believe are very
thoughtful um but this is in effect
training
liberals you know actual liberals and
people left of liberal
to view neo-liberalism as an
or to view neo-liberals as allies
against neo-fascists
okay
i think that's really dangerous
and it's it's just going to bite us in
the butt because
we tried that in the 2016 election with
hillary clinton it failed
and and so but but
the establishment just can't afford to
push us further to the left or to or let
the left lead because they've sold out
to corporations
you know so let me see if i understand
and dennis if there is a question coming
that would be great your position is
that
the center-left media like msnbc
is proposing
neo-liberalism
as a solution to the maga neo-fascism
that that's already failed and that it's
not a good path forward
that's right exactly well i agree with
that
it's but
what i'm asking you is yes i
this is paralyzing because it's i mean
anna navarro who's a moderate republican
correct yes
is someone whom i very much admire
and
you know she
but even though she's a conservative
she's now a liberal
in the view of kind of well she's
anti-trump she's anti-trump dennis
listen i i hate to do is there a
question because i have so many people
wanting to talk to me and we are trying
to take questions today
yes i'm i'm sorry david i
i'm i'm just i think my question is
dennis thank you i'm gonna i'm gonna go
uh okay we've gotta uh we've gotta move
on um just
completely uh um unable to speak there
um so overcome with emotion